DANA PERINO AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
FOX NEWS ALERT.
IT'S BEEN A BUSY 24 HOURS FOR
THE PRESIDENT AS HE TRIES TO
MAKE A DEAL WITH DEMOCRATS ON
BORDER SECURITY AND THE
SHUTDOWN.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE NOT GETTING
VERY FAR.
THE PRESIDENT REPORTEDLY WALKING
OUT OF A MEETING AFTER HE
COULDN'T REACH A DEAL WITH
DEMOCRATS.
IT ALSO STARTED LAST NIGHT AS HE
MADE HIS CASE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> EVERY DAY AND BORDER PATROL
AGENTS ENCOUNTER THOUSANDS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TRYING TO
ENTER OUR COUNTRY.
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER IS A
PIPELINE FOR A VAST QUANTITIES
OF ILLEGAL DRUGS.
OVER THE YEARS, THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN BRUTALLY
KILLED BY THOSE WHO ILLEGALLY
ENTERED OUR COUNTRY AND
THOUSANDS MORE LIVES WILL BE
LOST IF WE DON'T ACT RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS, A
CRISIS OF THE HEART AND A CRISIS
OF THE SOUL.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REMAINS
SHUTDOWN FOR ONE REASON AND ONE
REASON ONLY.
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS WILL NOT FUND
BORDER SECURITY.
>> Jesse: TODAY HE HAD LUNCH
ON CAPITOL HILL WITH REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS AND DOUBLED DOWN ON
HIS DEMANDS.
>> THE REPUBLICANS ARE UNIFIED.
WE WANT BORDER SECURITY.
WE WANT SAFETY FOR OUR COUNTRY.
THE ONLY REASON THEY ARE AGAINST
IT IS BECAUSE I WON THE
PRESIDENCY.
THEY THINK THEY CAN TRY AND HURT
US GOING INTO THE PRESIDENCY BUT
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND WE DON'T GIVE UP.
WE ARE DOING THE RIGHT THING.
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS AREN'T
BUDGING.
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER
JUST BROKE AFTER THEIR MEETING
WITH TRUMP EARLIER TODAY.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, THE PRESIDENT
JUST GOT UP AND WALKED OUT.
HE ASKED SPEAKER PELOSI, WILL
YOU AGREE TO MY WALL.
SHE SAID NO.
AND HE JUST GOT UP AND SAID THEN
WE HAVE NOTHING TO DISCUSS AND
HE JUST WALKED OUT.
I ASKED HIM TO OPEN UP THE
GOVERNMENT.
HE SAID IF I OPEN UP THE
GOVERNMENT, YOU WON'T DO WHAT I
WANT.
A FEW MINUTES LATER, HE SORT OF
SLAMMED THE TABLE AND LEADER
PELOSI SAID SHE DIDN'T AGREE
WITH THE WALL, HE WALKED OUT
INSIDE WE HAVE NOTHING TO
DISCUSS.
>> Jesse: VICE PRESIDENT PENCE
SAYS HE DOESN'T RECALL HIM
RAISING HIS VOICE OR SLAMMING
THE TABLE.
HE SAID HE WALKED INTO THE ROOM
AND PASSED OUT CANDY.
FOR DEMOCRATS, THE HEADLINES ARE
ALL ABOUT SCHUMER AND PELOSI'S
BIZARRE REBUTTAL WITH PUT THE
INTERNET ON OVERDRIVE.
ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR MEMES
WAS THE AMERICAN GRAPHIC PELOSI
AND SCHUMER.
ANOTHER ONE COMPARES THEM TO
YOUR ANGRY PARENTS FINDING OUT
THAT YOU SKIPPED SCHOOL.
THERE IS THIS ONE ASKING IF YOU
NEED TO HELP FOR AN ACCIDENT.
GREG, WHEN YOU SAW THESE TWO
PEOPLE THERE, WHAT WAS THE FIRST
THING THAT WENT THROUGH YOUR
MIND?
>> Greg: I THOUGHT THEY WERE
TRYING TO SELL ME A REVERSE
MORTGAGE.
HE WOULD HAVE TO GO TO THE LOCAL
CEMETERY TO FIND ANYTHING
STIFFER.
THEY WERE SHELLACKED.
THEY COULD NOT MOVE.
I WAS TALKING TO SOMEONE IN THE
GREEN ROOM.
IT WAS CLEAR THIS HAD BEEN
WRITTEN REGARDLESS OF WHAT TRUMP
WAS GOING TO SAY.
HE DIDN'T GIVE THEM ANYTHING TO
ACTUALLY IMPROV OR VAMP OFF OF.
EVERYTHING HE SAID WAS FACTUALLY
CORRECT.
YOU COULD TELL WITH THE
FACT-CHECKING HOW FORLORN
EVERYBODY WAS THAT THEY COULDN'T
FIND ANY MEAT ON THAT BONE.
INSTEAD, YOU HAVE LURCH AND
MORTICIA.
IS THAT THE ADDAMS FAMILY?
IS THAT THE MUNSTERS?
I GET THEM CONFUSED.
YOU WEREN'T EVEN BORN YET.
WHAT CONFUSED ME IS THAT HE
BROUGHT CANDY.
THIS IS CONSIDERED A PEACE
OFFERING.
THEY BASICALLY REBUFFED HIM
AFTER GIVING HIM CANDY.
YOU DON'T LIKE JOLLY RANCHERS.
>> Dana: I USED TO BUT THERE
COMES AN AGE WHEN YOU CAN'T EAT
THEM ANYMORE.
>> Jesse: I THINK I AM STILL
YOUNG ENOUGH TO HAVE A JOLLY
RANCHER.
>> Dana: I AM GOING TO HAVE A
STARBURST.
>> Jesse: JUAN, IF I GIVE YOU
THIS FROM GREG, DOESN'T MEAN
YOU'RE GOING TO AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING WE WANT?
>> Juan: YEAH, ROTTEN TEETH.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE A SWEET
TOOTH, JUAN.
>> Juan: I REALLY DO.
I LOVE SWEETS.
HERE'S THE THING THAT STRIKES
ME.
GREG PICKED UP ON THIS.
TRUMP SAID NOTHING.
>> Greg: I SET IT IN A GOOD
WAY.
>> Juan: BECAUSE YOU ARE GLAD
HE SAID NOTHING.
>> Greg: HE TALKED ABOUT ALL
THE CASUALTIES, THE VICTIMS.
>> Juan: IT WAS A NATIONAL
DRESS THAT THE NETWORKS GOT
SUCKERED INTO.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ASKED FOR A
NATIONAL TIME.
I GUESS HE'S GOING TO MAKE NEWS
BUT HE MAKES ZERO NEWS.
>> Dana: I DON'T THINK THE
PRESIDENT HAS TO MAKE NEWS TO
BEYOND.
>> Juan: THAT'S THE REASON
THAT YOU GET TIME.
>> Greg: HE STATED THE FACTS.
THE STATISTICS WERE PRETTY
CLEAR.
>> Juan: THERE IS A NATIONAL
CRISIS WHEN CROSSINGS ARE AT A
20 YEAR LOW.
>> Greg: "THE WASHINGTON POST"
SAID THAT YESTERDAY.
>> Juan: HEROIN IS COMING
ACROSS.
NOT ILLEGALLY IN TERMS OF
ILLEGAL CROSSINGS BUT COMING
THROUGH PORTS OF ENTRY.
THIS IS A GUY WHO SAYS WE HAVE A
SITUATION HERE WHERE THE TRADE
DEAL IS GOING TO PAY FOR THE
WALL.
NOBODY THINKS THE TRADE DEAL IS
PAYING FOR THE WALL.
CERTAINLY MEXICO IS NOT PAYING
FOR THE WALL.
TO ME, IT WAS LIKE --
>> Greg: DO YOU WANT TO
COUNTER THE PORT OF ENTRY
ARGUMENT?
>> Jesse: I KNEW YOU WERE
GOING TO BRING THAT UP, JUAN.
I WILL GIVE YOU THIS.
THEY SEIZED -- BORDER PATROL
AGENCIES FOR 200 POUNDS OF
FONTANELLE AT THE PORTS OF ENTRY
ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
BUT THEY ALSO SEIZED 332 POUNDS
OF FENTANYL ALONG THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THAT'S A LOT OF FENTANYL.
>> Greg: THE REASON WHY IT'S
AT THE PORT OF ENTRY IS BECAUSE
THAT'S OFTEN THE EASIER PATH
ONCE YOU HAVE BARRIERS.
IT ACTUALLY MOVES INTO THE PORT
OF ENTRY.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT YOU SAID HE
WANTS THE WALL.
IN OTHER WORDS --
>> Greg: YES.
SO --
>> Juan: I THINK WE ARE IN THE
WEEDS AND I THINK THIS IS WHAT
TRUMP DOES TO THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
HE GETS YOU ARGUING ABOUT WHERE
IS IT COMING FROM?
THERE IS NO CRISIS.
THAT'S THE POINT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE IN THE
MINORITY BECAUSE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAYS --
>> Juan: I AM JUST TALKING
FACTS.
>> Jesse: ARE YOU CALLING
"THE WASHINGTON POST" FAKE NEWS?
>> Greg: THERE IS NO CRISIS.
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
THERE IS NO CRISIS.
CHILDREN DIED.
>> Jesse: THE POLICE OFFICER
SHOT BY ILLEGAL ALIENS.
>> Juan: THIS IS THE PART THAT
I LIKE ABOUT WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TO SAY.
HE TALKED ABOUT HUMANITARIAN
ISSUES.
>> Greg: I THOUGHT THERE WAS
NO HUMANITARIAN ISSUE.
I THOUGHT THERE WAS NO CRISIS.
FIRST THERE'S NO CRISIS.
NOW THERE'S A CRISIS.
EAT SOME CANDY, JUAN.
>> Juan: HUMANITARIAN WHY WAS
IT NOT A CRISIS TWO YEARS AGO
WHEN REPUBLICANS HAD CONTROL OF
EVERYTHING.
>> Jesse: LET'S GET TO DANA.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW.
I WAS LISTENING TO YOU ALL.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA GAVE THE
PRIME TIME ADDRESS ON THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT?
WHAT DID REPUBLICANS -- REMEMBER
WE SAT HERE.
OH!
THAT'S NOT TRUE AND THAT'S NOT
GOING TO WORK AND THAT'S NOT THE
CASE.
OKAY, HERE'S THE THING.
HE HAD ENOUGH MEMBERS TO GET IT
PASSED.
HE PAID A POLITICAL PRICE FOR
IT.
I THINK THE JURY IS STILL OUT ON
THAT, THAT IT SOLD THE PROBLEMS
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BUT
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
I THINK RESIDENTS, EVEN IF THERE
ARE NOT GOING TO MAKE NEWS, IF
THE PRESIDENT SAYS I WANT TO
ADDRESS THE NATION, THE NETWORKS
SHOULD GIVE IT.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE ASKS ALL THE
TIME.
THIS IS HIS FIRST OVAL OFFICE
ADDRESS AND HE CHOSE TO DO IT ON
IMMIGRATION.
YOU CAN CHOOSE TO THINK THAT THE
SPEECH DIDN'T MOVE THE BALL.
SPEECH WAS FACTUALLY INCORRECT
BUT I THINK THAT THAT NETWORKS
DID THE RIGHT THING AND TAKING
THE SPEECH AND THAT, HE GETS
THIS REPUTATION FOR BEING
SOMEONE WHO WALKS AROUND THE
WHITE HOUSE FUMING ALL THE TIME.
CHUCK SCHUMER TODAY SAID HE'S
POUNDING THE TABLE.
THE WHITE HOUSE TRIES TO SAY NO,
HE'S QUITE RATIONAL.
HE EVEN BROUGHT CANDY.
HE IS SO NICE.
HE'S A FATHER AND A GRANDFATHER.
I THINK -- I DON'T THINK THEY
MADE A BIG DENT IN MOVING
ANYTHING EITHER WAY.
SO WE ARE AT AN IMPASSE.
BUT I DO THINK IT'S INTERESTING
THAT IS $5 BILLION.
I'M GOING TO SAY JUST $5 BILLION
IN THE BIG SCHEME OF THINGS IN
THE BUDGET.
ON FRIDAY WHEN THE PAYROLL
DOESN'T GOD, IT'S MORE THAN
$5 BILLION -- WHEN THE PAYROLL
DOESN'T GO OUT, IT'S MORE THAN
$5 BILLION.
WE'VE LOST SOME PERSPECTIVE.
>> Jesse: WAS THE OBAMA
ADDRESS THE ONE WHERE HE SAID IF
YOU LIKE YOUR HEALTH CARE, YOU
CAN KEEP IT.
EMILY, WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT
LAST NIGHT AND THE DEMOCRATIC
>> Emily: I HAVE BEEN A
FEDERAL ATTORNEY.
YOU KNOW.
YOU CONTINUE TO QUESTION IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: SHOW US YOUR RESUME.
>> Emily: I HAVE BEEN
FURLOUGHED AND HEADED OUT FOR
LOW PAPERS.
IT COMPARED TO THE DAY THAT I
WAS SITTING IN CHARGE OF FEDERAL
EMPLOYEES AND THERE WERE
GUNSHOTS OUT MY WINDOW AND THERE
WAS AN ACTIVE SHOOTER RUNNING
AROUND.
I WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
SAFETY AND ME.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY PELOSI
AND SCHUMER THROW AROUND
COMMENTS TODAY AND THEY RESPOND
SAYING THE WORDS TRAGIC AND
COLLATERAL DAMAGE, TALKING ABOUT
THE FURLOUGH WHEN IT'S A
DISINGENUOUS COMMENT WHEN OUR
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES ARE BEING
ASSAULTED AND MURDERED AT THE
BORDER.
WHEN OUR COMMUNITIES, MIDWESTERN
AND LOW INCOME AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING DECIMATED
BY THE DRUG WARS, DRUGS PORTING
OVER THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
I ENCOURAGE YOU AND EVERYONE TO
READ THE 2018 DEA DRUG THREAT
ASSESSMENT REPORT WHICH WAS
QUITE CLEAR ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
DRUGS FLOWING ACROSS THE BORDERS
IN PORTS OF ENTRY AND NOT AND
THE CRIPPLING EFFECT THAT THOSE
TRANSNATIONAL CARTELS HAVE ON
LITERALLY EVERYTHING IN OUR
SYSTEM, INCLUDING OUR PRISON
POPULATIONS AND INCLUDING
DIPLOMACY AND BUREAUCRACY AND
POLITICS.
ENTIRE TOWNS THAT ARE LITERALLY
IN THE PALMS OF THEIR HANDS.
WHEN THEY SAY THE WALL IS A
MORALITY ISSUE OR THEY TALK
ABOUT THIS, ALL OF THESE
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES AT THE
MOMENT, TO ME THERE IS GREATER
CONSEQUENCES WE ARE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE BEING LOST IN
THE OVERSIMPLIFIED RESPONSE TO
THE NATIONAL CONVERSATION.
>> Juan: HOW DOES A WALL SOLVE
THAT?
IF THE DRUGS ARE COMING THROUGH
LEGAL PORTS OF ENTRY, A WALL IS
NOT GOING TO STOP IT.
>> Emily: NUMBER ONE, THE
PRESIDENT ISN'T JUST TALKING
ABOUT A PHYSICAL BARRIER BUDDIES
ALSO CALLED FOR FUNDING FOR
TECHNOLOGY FOR GREATER
REINFORCEMENTS.
JUDGES, IMMIGRATION JUDGES.
>> Juan: WITH THE DEMOCRAT
SAID TODAY AS IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDS AND
FORCES ON THE BORDER, TO DEAL
WITH THINGS LIKE THAT, WE WILL
NEGOTIATE.
BUT LET'S NOT SHUTDOWN THE
GOVERNMENT OVER THIS --
>> Jesse: THE SAME WALL THAT
THEY VOTED FOR FIVE YEARS AGO.
>> Greg: 4600 MILES OF WALL.
>> Jesse: IF THE DEMOCRATS